[Music]  incredible heat wave on the east coast  right now it was 98 degrees  in new york city today and we wanted to  do something nice for our east coast  viewers we wanted to help them cool down  a little bit  so here to read a series of chilling  facts that will cool you down instantly  is master thespian dennis hayes birth  [Applause]  [Applause]  every year  over 100 people choked to death  on ballpoint pens  in tennessee  an elephant was once hanged for murder  if injected intravenously nutmeg is  extremely poisonous  our eyes stay the same size from birth  but our nose and ears never stop growing  a hippo can open its mouth wide enough  to fit a four foot tall child inside  or dwarf  can run faster than humans  [Music]  a hippo's razor sharp tusks  can bite a small boat in half  actor dennis hayes bird  has an irrational and crippling fear of  [Music]  ladies and hippos  i took a very odd turn all right